bonjour david vous êtes en direct des
revan sous la neige
on le voit bien nouvelle journée de
mobilisation prévue aujourd'hui contre
le premier ministre
comment est ce que vont se dérouler les
choses et bien magali olivier il faut
savoir que nikol pashinian n'a appelé
tous ses partisans à se réunir à 18h30
place de la république pour montrer à
l'opposition que le premier ministre a
encore un soutien populaire indéfectible
voilà l'objectif premier
adieu premier ministre à nikol pashinian
à qui vous le savez est totalement
d'histoire avec son président qui a
refusé la démission du chef d'état major
de l'armée
il a réitéré cette demande sur facebook
cette demande pour l'instant elle n'a
pas de réponse il faut savoir qui est
également ce 1er mars 2021 et un triste
anniversaire puisque le 1er mars à 2008
de violents affrontements avaient eu
lieu entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants et qui étaient là pour
protester contre l'élection
présidentielle est de jeu serge
sarkissian à d'où un appel au calme
lancés à part à nikol pashinian hier sur
les réseaux sociaux afin d'éviter des
affrontements similaires qui avaient tué
10 personnes
je le rappelle en mars 2008 écoutez le
premier ministre arménien nicheurs troc
com very leur building mars certains
représentants des forces politiques
seront invités à participer à la
manifestation
nous leur proposerons également de
prendre la parole lors de la
manifestation pour que celle de demain
servent dans le fond les deux objectifs
que j'ai mentionnés il tenait instinct
me rappelle mon corps ou gère tout le
premier objectif
je le répète est de montrer qu'en
république d'arménie
il y à une société forte une société qui
peut former et protéger son pouvoir
je parle bien de la société pas du
gouvernement
le second objectif est de montrer qu'en
arménie la page des affrontements civile
du 1er mars est tournée je veux dire
qu'il est exclu que ce genre de
situation se reproduise
et nous pouvons tous ensemble être
garant de ce processus avant tout le
gouvernement bien sûr mais aussi la
société et en parallèle comme chaque
jour depuis jeudi une mobilisation anti
nikol pashinian va s'organiser
ici à 18h heure locale et comme vous le
voyez derrière moi des tentes ont été
érigées juste devant le parlement
arménien afin de maintenir cette
contestation populaire on va rentrer à
l'intérieur pour voir un peu comment ça
se passe et comment les manifestants se
relaient tous les jours afin de
maintenir cette pression populaire vous
le voyez un sur ces images voilà c'est
très vétustes des bancs sont installés
tout autour de cette coupe une cheminée
de fortune également ou une réserve de
voix est là pour que les tous les
manifestants se relaient afin de
maintenir cette pression populaire
malgré ce froid hivernal a comme vous
avez pu le voir il neige aujourd'hui et
c'est prévu pour toute la semaine et
bien les manifestants ne compte pas
abandonner jusqu'au départ du premier
ministre arménien considéré comme un
paria considéré comme un traître depuis
cette défaite militaire dans le haut
karabagh vécu comme une humiliation
nationale pour la plupart de ces
manifestants en tout cas cette
mobilisation ici anti nikol pashinian
prévue à 18 heures heure locale
elle devrait être encadrée fortement par
les forces de l'ordre un important
dispositif de sécurité va être mis en
place afin d'éviter tout affrontement
avec les manifestants pro nicole phase
finale puisque la place de la république
n'est pas très loin d'ici
donc l'objectif premier est évidemment
et d'éviter tous ces affrontements
violents et ne pas revivre
effectivement ce 1er mars 2008 et qui
avait a tué dix personnes lors
d'affrontements entre forces de l'ordre
et manifestants merci beaucoup david
pour toutes ces précisions rester bien
au chaud sous la tente david qualify on
va suivre bien sûr toutes ces
manifestations dans nos prochaines
éditions